[SPEAKER_00]: Second Wealsun, round 9, 15.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul and Jude summon the garrison captain to have a discussion regarding the helm and the defenses there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so the captain comes in and says, Prince Elf, how can I help you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, Captain, we would like to know how much hobgoblins, if you had to estimate, are on here on this island.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can tell you that we have seen at least a hundred.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have noticed hobgoblins coming in and out of the garrison, the helm.
[SPEAKER_00]: How they got there, we have no idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: I assume that they captured the helm and the guards that were there, which was 150 strong.
[SPEAKER_00]: But we've only seen about a hundred patrol this way.
[SPEAKER_00]: There have been groups of 20 to 30 that we've seen on other parts of the island.
[SPEAKER_00]: Also, the different beacons
[SPEAKER_00]: They've all gone blank.
[SPEAKER_00]: So obviously there are hobgoblins there.
[SPEAKER_00]: We don't know if there's one squad, two squad or whatever, but I would assume that considering the number of men we had there, there were at least 20 to 40 that attacked and took that place to take those places.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was possible.
[SPEAKER_00]: This includes the Southern as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I think we were signaling to them and they basically said that
[SPEAKER_00]: In that island area, they encountered 50.
[SPEAKER_00]: They've killed 20, but that leaves 30 more.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, all told, I think we can safely assume there are more than 200.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what I was estimating.
[SPEAKER_00]: That seems to be something that a warship would carry.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, for some reason, we have not been able to see a warship in the docks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there any place where a warship could anchor and offload on the other side of the home?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there any safe anchorage?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I mean, if there's safe anchorage and they were doing it during the night, or they had some inside men, otherwise, I'd have to assume something much worse, which could be they have some sort of...
[SPEAKER_00]: It was the fog storm.
[SPEAKER_00]: The storm.
[SPEAKER_00]: It completely made our visibility...
[SPEAKER_00]: So you couldn't even see the bay?
[SPEAKER_00]: We could see nothing.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was soup.
[SPEAKER_00]: You couldn't see five feet ahead of you.
[SPEAKER_00]: So they could have snuck in under that, and that's what we assume happened.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, when it cleared, our lookouts would be able to see this direction, this direction.
[SPEAKER_00]: We couldn't see this direction, but we know from these men, there are no ships on that side.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I would say if there is a ship...
[SPEAKER_02]: Right, but if they were transported in, then it would have been during the fog.
[SPEAKER_00]: It would have been during the fog.
[SPEAKER_00]: They could have landed here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And there still could be, so there is some anchorage there.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's an approach to the beach.
[SPEAKER_00]: They could anchor off there and then they could use longshore boats to get off there.
[SPEAKER_00]: How they took the helm, though, I have no idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, it could have been at night, but how they got into the gates...
[SPEAKER_00]: I would assume...
[SPEAKER_00]: It would be impossible, I mean...
[SPEAKER_00]: I would assume that they had an infiltrator, or a sagitturum, or... And somebody lowered the drawbridge, or the bridge.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's no moat, however, there is a ramp up to the entrance, and there is a drawbridge that lowers to allow people into the keep.
[SPEAKER_00]: The fortifications are impressive.
[SPEAKER_00]: If they have 150 men, they can basically defend all sides of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just as an aside, and if you have no knowledge of this, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is fresh water brought in from the outside, or are there wells?
[SPEAKER_00]: Fresh water is shipped in.
[SPEAKER_00]: There is no fresh water naturally occurring here except through rain.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are cisterns.
[SPEAKER_00]: When it rains, they capture it, and that's how most of it gets here, but fresh water is usually required.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there any kind of a subterranean sewer system or anything that goes out?
[SPEAKER_00]: He kind of looks at you and then he looks at you and says, well, this is a state secret, but I assume since Prince John sent you here, you can know this.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are supposedly secret entrances to underneath the helm.
[SPEAKER_00]: There is a cave system that is navigable by boat, small boat, into a subterranean cave system underneath the helm itself.
[SPEAKER_00]: This was once an old smuggler's fortification hundreds of years ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've never been there, and it's something that the Admiralty does not let anyone go into.
[SPEAKER_00]: But there are rumors that it's on this side of the island.
[SPEAKER_00]: If they had knowledge of that, they could have penetrated.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's possible that could have been an entrance, but how they got up through the underground caverns is another thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no knowledge of this.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is a rumor.
[SPEAKER_02]: Of course, of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I did ask about subterranean sewage system I was concerned about.
[SPEAKER_02]: Mostly I was asking because I was concerned about the sahaugin being able to penetrate anywhere on the island through any kind of like water access tunnels.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is what is strange.
[SPEAKER_00]: Historically the sahaugin have never been able to come to this island.
[SPEAKER_00]: This island is supposedly protected by a magical
[SPEAKER_00]: Enchantment that kills sahaugin as soon as they come.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sharks cannot even come near the waters here within a mile.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who maintains that or is that...
[SPEAKER_00]: This is the way it's been for a hundred years.
[SPEAKER_00]: The fact that the sahaugin are able to reach these beaches puts us at a great disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Otherwise our ships would be all around this island.
[SPEAKER_00]: Defending it from the sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Admiralty has been able to maintain this enchantment for over a hundred years now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ever since the Great Sahaugin Wars.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that enchantment linked to the Turtle Dragons?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or the Dragons of the Dragon Eyes?
[SPEAKER_00]: I know nothing of that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have heard that
[SPEAKER_00]: Turtle dragons like sahuagins as much as they like sharks to eat.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I assume sahuagins flee from turtle dragons.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who would not?
[SPEAKER_00]: But shark is turtle dragon's favorite food, so I assume that extends to the shark man.
[SPEAKER_02]: That could be if their protection was withdrawn, which we're already facing that possibility just with the blockade on Monmurg and the Sea Principalities in general.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that might be a tightening of the blockade.
[SPEAKER_02]: As a non-native from the Sea Principalities, though I have spent considerable time in Monmurg, do you notice anything strange with the hobgoblins' gear?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there any unique variations of marine gear, marine soldier gear, between the princes?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, are you able to spot...
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll notice that the design is the same for most of us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Scale armor and so on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Studded for the archers and such.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you notice that as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Their commanders wear breastplates like myself.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know of any such prints that would have the colors that the hobgoblins have, however.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are those colors Lord Fairwinds?
[SPEAKER_00]: These are the Lord Fairwinds colors.
[SPEAKER_00]: Blue.
[SPEAKER_00]: What color were the hobgoblins?
[SPEAKER_00]: They're kind of a weird sort of brownish-red.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so when he's saying that he doesn't know, he's saying that that color is not... Not of the princes that he knows.
[SPEAKER_00]: He basically says blue for Fairwind, green for Monmurg, the Toli, who I would assume would be the ones we would be in combat with considering the political system.
[SPEAKER_00]: Got you.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so these are a mottled kind of, what color did you say?
[SPEAKER_00]: Kind of a brownish red.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not a color of the Indian princess.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you're right to say that, Elf.
[SPEAKER_00]: Their armor is much like ours.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, next question we have is,
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you think it'd be wise to charge the helm and take it back with what force we have?
[SPEAKER_00]: We would die instantly.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, the helm is a fortification that has, you can put archers on the top, they have great advantage of height.
[SPEAKER_00]: The only way in the door, except for these
[SPEAKER_00]: Tunnels.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tunnels, supposedly, is through the front gate.
[SPEAKER_00]: The walls are 50 feet high.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are...
[SPEAKER_02]: So we would have to take the front gate and in a similar manner allow you to come in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_00]: And every section...
[SPEAKER_00]: The Garrison House, the Giant Tower, the Inner Sanctum, the Sanctuary.
[SPEAKER_00]: All of them have their own defensives and all of them are partitioned.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's amazing to me that the hobgoblins were able to penetrate so easily.
[SPEAKER_00]: So once in, that's just the beginning of your headache.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: This area, here's the gate and the Garrison.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then to get to the Tower, there are other fortifications you have to have here.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, most men never go beyond this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Only private guards are in the inner sanctum.
[SPEAKER_02]: And if Lord Fairwind were in the inner sanctum or sanctuary, hold up, as you had mentioned before, if he still had any sizable force left, which let's say his force at least had been cut, reduced by two-thirds if they were caught by surprise, if we, in your opinion, if we were able to take the gate
[SPEAKER_02]: Storm in, would there be any advantage if we were also able to link up with Lord Fairwind's men and he were able to come out from the inside?
[SPEAKER_02]: So access into if we were able to take the gate.
[SPEAKER_02]: By we, as you know, there's an agent coming from the tower.
[SPEAKER_02]: You were privy to those messages when he's coming with some of his select men.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we will probably be trying to penetrate by one way or the other, perhaps search for those.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you mean to rescue my lord?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, that's what we were thinking.
[SPEAKER_02]: If he still has survived and secure the hell.
[SPEAKER_00]: Even if he were to bring down the front gate and allow our men to enter, which would be a great advantage, it would be a fight through the main tower.
[SPEAKER_00]: But if Lord Verwin was able to also sally out with any amount of troops?
[SPEAKER_00]: It would help.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, there's no doubt about that.
[SPEAKER_00]: It would depend on how many men he has and how many men they have.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think it would be very, very disastrous for us to charge to the gate and we're outnumbered.
[SPEAKER_00]: We would fight that, but still.
[SPEAKER_02]: Would you anticipate any reason for Hobgoblin troops to sally out to retake the tower on the island?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not sure what we call this.
[SPEAKER_00]: This?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that the South Tower?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's the South Beacon and the Garrison House.
[SPEAKER_02]: That might be some way, but they would know that they would be in danger from passing of getting cut off if they sent any sizable troops.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because you have 150, now they would know of the Marines from the beach.
[SPEAKER_02]: So they would know roughly that we have 170 men.
[SPEAKER_00]: True.
[SPEAKER_00]: We would be able to block anyone that tried to go this way.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we would sell it out if we outnumbered them, definitely.
[SPEAKER_00]: We could consider recapturing the Western Beacon, that's possible, or even these other places.
[SPEAKER_00]: Assault on the Hell would be very close.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was going to say, we could draw them out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, or at least try to secure the rest of the other Beacon places.
[SPEAKER_02]: That way we could warrant off any shipping from any of the other Prince items.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I think we could do, is try and draw them out and cause the chaos to cause them out in the open.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does this barracks house any repair equipment for the beacons?
[SPEAKER_02]: New, bronze, polished?
[SPEAKER_02]: We have supply for the oil.
[SPEAKER_02]: But not if the beacon itself has been removed as you heard in the messages from the south tower?
[SPEAKER_00]: We have extra abrasions that we can put at the top, and we have the materials to create a fire force signal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: But, to be honest, I think that the worrisome thing is until the sahaugin are repelled, I don't see us getting any relief.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why the enchantment was broken, we do not know.
[SPEAKER_00]: I assume that Lord Fairwind, who is responsible for the enchantment's effect, only the Admiralty know how this enchantment is made.
[SPEAKER_00]: So Fairwind would know, and he would also know why it was broken.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does pharaoh have magical capabilities, to your knowledge?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm unsure if the princes do.
[SPEAKER_02]: Would he be able to reinstate the shield if he were in a compromised manner, but if we were able to rescue him?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, the truth is, I don't know if Fairwind...
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know the mechanism.
[SPEAKER_02]: Of course, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not a wizard, and I have not been briefed.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is a state secret, very, very well-kept state secret on how this protection has been maintained all these years.
[SPEAKER_00]: And only the Admiralty know the truth of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: In regards to the possible tunnels, the smuggling tunnels, do you have anybody under your command that's old, that's been on this island or served on this island?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no knowledge of any of this, and knowing such a thing would be considered treasonous.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are pilots that know this, but none of them are under my command.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're directly under the command of the Admiralty.
[SPEAKER_00]: So nothing other than a vague reference?
[SPEAKER_00]: It is on the north side of the island, along the coast somewhere.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is a well-hidden cave, and the waters are very dangerous near there.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's difficult to pilot.
[SPEAKER_00]: And only a small ship... And only accessible by water?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Even the tide does not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not to mention the...
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, that would be a way to come in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but the shark people, they eat us up so fast.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but they wouldn't expect us if we were able to do it stealthily.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, until we're not.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's always like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's always good until it's not.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't want to try being stealthy.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're chit-chatting in front of him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you think it's possible for us to...
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't see how we can assault the helm.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, we can't get the magic shield up without rescuing Ward Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_00]: Undoubtedly.
[SPEAKER_00]: And also we have to retake the large tower for the signal fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, to the DM, were you suggesting that these, if they were with braziers and fires, these are still not the main Sigma fire to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_02]: So, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you could definitely signal.
[SPEAKER_00]: And actually, the truth is having those back would be good because shipping at night would be able to see what the hell.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we can warn them off.
[SPEAKER_00]: Taking those back would be very helpful to shipping.
[SPEAKER_00]: And also, you'd be able to communicate better with Monmurg, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I think what the captain is saying is this enchantment that repels the sahaugin... That's a major problem that it's down.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's the biggest problem that we've got.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because reinforcements could come and they'll just swamp the bay, depending upon how many sahaugin, but they were able to take out 200 marines on a ship.
[SPEAKER_02]: So unless it's a full-on assault with a thousand marines or whatever, depending upon how many sahaugin they are.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I mean I get that that's a problem.
[SPEAKER_02]: How would you take back the other two towers, given that we hold the South Tower?
[SPEAKER_02]: What would you recommend?
[SPEAKER_00]: This one will be difficult basically because we would be underneath the shadow of the cliffs for the helm.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if they wanted to bring out troops they could fire down upon us.
[SPEAKER_00]: This one would be easier.
[SPEAKER_00]: The western beacon would be easier.
[SPEAKER_00]: We could probably march out tonight with maybe 50 men and depending on how many enemy were there we could probably take that back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's say that if there were 50 here, let's suggest that possibly there's 50-50, that would be 150.
[SPEAKER_02]: You said that you've seen 150 march out from here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that would put us in that 250 to 300 range that you suspect.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you could probably count on at least 50 men holding each one of these places.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are we concerned about 30 men in the interior?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, your fortifications, obviously, for the barracks, it's...
[SPEAKER_00]: I would want to leave 70 men in the barracks to protect it at any one time.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: That would leave 100 men for these assaults.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think, at this point, it would be prudent to split our forces.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if we would assault one of the beacons... Do it with maximum... Do it with maximum force.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take it, leave a garrison, and then move on.
[SPEAKER_01]: How many hobgoblins have we killed?
[SPEAKER_00]: You have killed 20.
[SPEAKER_00]: We've heard that the Southern Garrison had 20 killed.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have killed none.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, probably right on that 250 range.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right, right on the 250.
[SPEAKER_02]: So let's say we winnowed down their resources, so they're rolling about like where we're at.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe a little bit more.
[SPEAKER_02]: But they hold the high ground on the fortifications.
[SPEAKER_01]: I say we get the tower or the beacon.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, if we took the tower and it was quick, he might even be able to turn around and march on that, even just if it's a distraction.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm sure that Monmurg's agent, Gouge, is going to want to penetrate the helm.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's gonna want to do it tonight.
[SPEAKER_00]: It would be very difficult for someone to be able to climb the walls without being seen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do an inside roll, Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nat 20.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dwight, you want me to step out?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: It might be possible actually to do it if there was a distraction.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe an attack from the moraines and then possibly people infiltrate over the walls?
[SPEAKER_00]: To get the hull.
[SPEAKER_00]: To get into the hull?
[SPEAKER_01]: So if we do a distraction by... An assault.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I was thinking.
[SPEAKER_01]: Draw all of the tension.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I speak of this to the captain.
[SPEAKER_01]: Role play.
[SPEAKER_01]: If we cause a distraction on the helm with an assault, isn't there a fair chance that we have to get into the helm?
[SPEAKER_02]: From the seaside?
[SPEAKER_00]: If there's an assault on Mange, here, possibly you could infiltrate.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'd have to climb the wall and get on top of the garrison here.
[SPEAKER_00]: From there, you could drop down into the courtyard.
[SPEAKER_00]: It would take somebody that is very skilled in climbing to be able to get up there.
[SPEAKER_00]: The walls are difficult.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're 50 feet high.
[SPEAKER_00]: And, of course, they would have to be able to get up the cliffs as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, with ropes and giving gouges skills, also I can levitate.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have magic?
[SPEAKER_00]: You didn't see the fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: Magic that would allow you to rise up?
[SPEAKER_00]: It would be a small group, but I think that is what I would worry of.
[SPEAKER_00]: The men on top of the hill, the top of the walls, would be able to kill anyone that tried to rise up.
[SPEAKER_00]: But if we were attacking and they left just a small group here, or maybe on the tower, a small force could come in from behind.
[SPEAKER_00]: And from there...
[SPEAKER_02]: Would you be able to, with the least loss of life, provide that distraction?
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously not a full-on assault, you said that you would get killed.
[SPEAKER_02]: Would you be able to marshal a show of force, draw attention?
[SPEAKER_00]: We could march up the stairs, we could begin to assemble a battering ram, and then fire long range on the walls, exchange fire with the hobgoblins there.
[SPEAKER_02]: How long do you think to take 100 men here to take the tower tonight?
[SPEAKER_00]: It depends on how many enemies are there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's say no more than 50.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know about how defensive that position is or what 50 men holding it looks like.
[SPEAKER_00]: That would probably be a two-hour operation.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if during that, to secure our rear, that was our time limit and our window to get into place, would you then be able to marshal and start to at least maneuver in front, you know, as a show of aggression, building the battering ram, perhaps, or assembling it to draw attention to the front?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, that would be possible.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does it make sense that it would be done at night?
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess with fires to light the field around and such?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or would that be something that would be better done at dawn?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think that there would be any suspicion or difference with attacking at night.
[SPEAKER_00]: The reason I say that is that we are in desperate straits.
[SPEAKER_02]: So they would anticipate...
[SPEAKER_00]: The beacon, taking the south, the western beacon would be logical because obviously we need to have that up for the shipping.
[SPEAKER_00]: And to have that reignited at night would be a logical thing for us to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: It would also, if we assaulted the main helm, they would take it a attempt.
[SPEAKER_00]: A desperate.
[SPEAKER_00]: Desperate attempt.
[SPEAKER_00]: But the assault would happen at night.
[SPEAKER_00]: Logically I would do it at night anyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if we were able to get this going, it would be perhaps after taking, provided there's no complications, you would be able to signal, if you were able to secure the tower, we would either be able to signal that we were in position to scale, and then you could sometime around maybe 1 or 2 a.m. be prepared to demonstrate?
[SPEAKER_02]: You wouldn't want to signal.
[SPEAKER_00]: We would make the assault at 2 a.m., and then you could begin whatever you would do.
[SPEAKER_00]: If it was something that you wished to do.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ropes?
[SPEAKER_00]: I assume you have plenty of just basic... We have ropes, yes, definitely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because what I can do is I can also... Well, I can levitate.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can't levitate everybody, but depending upon...
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I could rise up, at least gouge, and perhaps another one of his, but if they took ropes, they could be climbing while they were finishing off, or at least... Or you could just hold the rope and then secure it on the wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: Levitate yourself.
[SPEAKER_00]: Firewall around you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Step off and then throw rope over the side.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'd like to not draw that much attention.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd like to maneuver, hopefully stealthily, inside of the game.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, fireball.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can we retrieve any of the bodies if we need their armor specifically from the bay, like Undercover of Darkness, any of the hobgoblin bodies that were left?
[SPEAKER_00]: We can send patrols out, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, just to secure the bodies, no risk, but hopefully, you know, I mean, make them...
[SPEAKER_02]: Because if we can get those equipment, then once we're inside, we might be able to, I don't know, pass at least from a distance as hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you have performance and disguise kit skills.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, well not me, but you know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to start fashioning a hobgoblin mask?
[SPEAKER_00]: Ooh, do you do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I could try to do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to scan one of their faces?
[SPEAKER_01]: Get you a body.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll just do some paper mache or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have that as a disguise?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I've done it before.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, I've done, like, face, like, because I've made masks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's an assassin.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's got a disguise kit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's not a master of it yet, but...
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you could get started on that one.
[SPEAKER_02]: We could ask if you need a body brought back as well as just whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know if they wore any helmets that would also disguise a little bit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, you know, do they have...
[SPEAKER_02]: They have helmets.
[SPEAKER_02]: So then you just need a facsimile in the dark of, like, if they've got a bulbous nose, then... A bulbous nose.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, like, you know, you make a big old honkin' nose.
[SPEAKER_01]: One body so I can just see what they look like.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know, lots of hair.
[SPEAKER_02]: You could shave some of them bald if you need.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I could do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Pointy ears.
[SPEAKER_01]: Red skin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, red skin.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, red, dye.
[SPEAKER_02]: We can paint our skin red, or our faces.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oof, jeez.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, so then I ask for at least any of the bodies that he can bring in that are, their armor's still good.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, if somebody's burned to death or whatever and their armor's all burned up, of course, then no.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, but arms, weapons, and
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, and any bodies that we could like that still have an intact face at least to go by.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know, I mean...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so collect bodies.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, collect some bodies.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we can get some gear so that Gouge's troops could be disguised and or yourself and myself at least in armor or whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, I can't wear armor, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're clothing, they're clothes.
[SPEAKER_02]: So my idea is that when Gouge gets here we actually have a plan for the south tower, so that's going to be under the captain's command, or the western tower, and we have a loose plan so that he can kind of like survey it, give it a rough assessment, and if he wants to move this night, which I'm assuming he will, we've got at least the rough outlines of the plan going so that we can kind of hit the ground running.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can you think of anything else that might help us with subterfuge or stealth?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, not really.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, the more people we take, the harder it's going to be.
[SPEAKER_02]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I would imagine it's not going to take a five-man crew.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think leaving them under the command of the captain so that he has maximum to defend the barracks.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was going to say, most people I would ever take is five.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know how many henchmen gouge has, but it won't be many, knowing gouge.
[SPEAKER_02]: He doesn't trust anybody anyways.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would suggest that you prepare your troops and plan to take the Western Tower, and when the agent from Monmurg, when gouge arrives, we'll discuss further with him if he thinks, or if he has any variations on the plan.
[SPEAKER_02]: And potentially prepare to maneuver, which would be assembling.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would like there to be the least amount of loss of men, especially given that the sahaugin is still a problem for holding this island.
[SPEAKER_02]: So don't waste lives at the front gate, unless you see me blowing up, you know, people at the front gate.
[SPEAKER_02]: Napalm strike on the wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: This sounds like a decent plan.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, Paul, are you going to be part of the group that goes and infiltrates the helm?
[SPEAKER_00]: So you agree with this?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll prepare for the assault on the beacon.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you wish this to happen?
[SPEAKER_00]: An hour from now?
[SPEAKER_00]: Before your agents get here?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or after?
[SPEAKER_02]: After.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you wish to talk to them before we execute this plan?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, we would like to.
[SPEAKER_02]: But if they take a while to get here, they still have to get past roughly... We'll give them like an hour.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's 30 hobgoblins are in the interior somewhere in here.
[SPEAKER_00]: They'll be fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is a thousand feet.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if they're going this way... Is this forest?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's like...
[SPEAKER_00]: Jungle.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's sort of like jungle trees.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not thick, though.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like sun cover.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if there were 30 men massing, we would see it.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's also dark, so they've got a stone.
[SPEAKER_01]: They'll be fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, well I would say be ready to take that tower or move on the western tower no later than, he said about two hours, so no later than maybe eleven, but let's wait until then.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like you're not to move yet but get your troops ready to take the western tower and then to demonstrate or to make a feint at the front gate.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll get the bodies right now and prepare the men.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll prepare two squads to take the western beacon.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so he leaves.